right now I'm putting myself at risk of
being sued why while I'm filming in
public in Paris in France and French
privacy law is some of the strictest and
worse defined in the world see it's been
built over years not by lawmakers but by
judges and case law and what it means is
this just having someone identifiable in
the back of my shot even if I then don't
publish it might be grounds for someone
to sue me or maybe it won't it's unclear
there are cases that have gone both ways
maybe I should blur anyone's face who's
even remotely in the back of shut or
maybe I shouldn't it's still unclear
maybe if there's any modern architecture
in the back of the shot I should blow it
out because that's copyrighted or maybe
under some other cases it isn't one
thing has been clear though I can take a
photo of the Eiffel Tower in daytime and
it's fine it's not under copyright
anymore but if I take a photo at night
the lighting design on it that is
copyrighted and so I'd need a license
before I were to publish that online to
make matters even more complicated I am
British and I'll be publishing this when
I'm in Britain to YouTube which is an
American company which has an office in
France it would be a complete mess maybe
I'd win if someone brought a case
against me maybe I wouldn't but either
way there'd be a long and costly
legal battle British law has a
reasonable expectation of privacy in
your own home or in a private place but
in public if you're filmed there's not
much you can do about it American law is
much the same
based on their First Amendment and their
very strong freedom of speech laws but
here while friends puts the power very
much in the individual and their right
to privacy over my right to film them
maybe that's right maybe that's wrong
and as for all these tourists around
here taking photos well let's hope
nobody Sue's them
ba-bye Duggan